[Music]
ben had an elbow injury to his right
elbow as being evaluated ben
roethlisberger has sustained a right
elbow injury in the first half
quarterback mason rudolph will get the
start we will guys keep you posted we
understand the position we're in we
understand the negativity that comes
with it
we better absorb it
we better get singularly focused and get
better for our next opportunity control
the things that we can control that's
what we intend to do but today
you know as painful as it should be
ben rothersberger done for the year
surgery will be conducted on that elbow
that was
in i mean it sounds like the injury was
already there that there was an issue
with it mason rudolph the new
quarterback mentioned on monday that
that he was aware coming out of the loss
to the patriots there was an issue with
ben's elbow but whatever was gone wrong
in there is now gone and needs to be
surgically fixed he's done for the year
mason rudolph takes over you know
there's a sense out there guys that
mason rudolph actually looked pretty
good on sunday against the seahawks and
some would say he looked even better
than big ben chris what was your
assessment well i'm not going to go that
far quite yet but mason rudolph i will
he did look good he did i mean he's he's
a little better athlete than ben
roethlisberger so he can move around and
do things like that at this point of the
you know his career compared to ben
and certainly didn't look like he was
you know deer in the headlight syndrome
or or out of place that way so we'll see
and i you know you know me mike i
haven't watched the film of that game
yet that'll that'll tell me a lot but uh
i did like what i saw from mason rudolph
and i think he does give them a fighting
chance nonetheless
it's the rest of their team i worry
about just as much as anything uh as the
quarterback right now i mean the
steelers are i don't know what they are
at this point
i totally agree with with chris i mean
the problem with this injury coming
right now
is that it's not like you have le'veon
bell and antonio brown right pick up a
young quarterback who's never played in
the nfl before this is a situation where
your line doesn't look quite as good as
it did under mike munchak uh your
offensive weapons certainly are not as
good as they have been in the past
and you're asking a young kid just off a
college campus basically to come in and
save your season it's a dangerous year
for the steelers i don't expect a lot
now out of the steelers and it's
how fast the nfl moves right because
think about this
who picked the baltimore ravens to be
the dominant team
in the end in the afc north i don't know
anybody who did and right now after
eight or nine days of the nfl season the
baltimore ravens looked to me to be as
solid a pick other than new england in
the in the afc they look to be as solid
a pick as any division in football yeah
well and quarterback injuries and we say
this every year injuries are going to
happen we just don't know when to whom
and how long the guy is going to be out
and it's inevitable and when everyone's
in the best shape of their lives right
training camp hey everybody looks great
everybody's happy the glass is half full
hell the glass is 95 full everyone's
great everything's great then you start
playing the games and you lose nick
foles and then ben rothersburg and drew
brees and this guy and that guy so i
mean that's what happens and the
steelers now have no expectations they
are essentially where the cults were
three weeks and three days ago and it
seems like it's been three years and
three months ago that andrew luck
retired but now we see what the steelers
can do without that burden that went
along with them going into the season
maybe mason rudolph can't get it done
and if mason rudolph gets injured we're
down to devlin hodges guys from samford
not stanford
samford
undrafted he had 475 yards in 2018
against florida state not that the
seminoles of the powerhouse they once
were but they like this kid and hey the
way the nfl is going we may see devlin
hodges by the third quarter coming up
this sunday at san francisco on behalf
of the steelers yeah no doubt uh peter
and i were at training camp up in
pittsburgh together you know i got uh
the the red carpet treatment because i'm
with the legend of peter king right so
that was really cool but he had a little
buzz
uh
as far as devlin hodges in the training
camp yeah you know i'll you know charlie
batch you know x steelers quarterback he
you know i just talk and ball with them
and he goes hey watch this hodges guy he
goes man it's not like the most
beautiful thing he's not gonna like wow
you every day because my every day he
comes out here and makes plays and makes
throws and moves the offense and he had
an impressive day uh the day peter and i
were there so the kid's got a little
moxy and he knows how to play the game
that's for sure i don't think they'll
fall off the planet if he does have to
get in the game
mike you talk about the colts the one
difference between uh the steelers of
today and the colts of three weeks ago
is that the colts had jacoby brissette
and the steelers obviously right now
head into the total unknown and they
head into the unknown at 0-2
and
you know this is i think this is going
to be one of those rare seasons in
pittsburgh where they're playing out the
string by december 1st
and that's what makes the decision to
give up next year's first round pick
which could be a top 10 pick which they
could use to get their next quarterback
to get cornerback minka fitzpatrick from
the miami dolphins that was the trade
that landed last night during the monday
night football game and it surprised a
lot of people that was the destination
chris and yeah i know that that you've
got some strong feelings about this the
idea that the steelers would give up
that first round pick that could indeed
be a high first round pick to bring in a
guy that maybe they don't need in that
defense i i don't get it i really don't
i don't really get the logic i like
minka fitzpatrick i really do now the
steelers for one okay i mean was this is
this a band-aid i mean now that you got
minka fitzpatrick are you gonna win
football games i don't i don't think
it's that big of a move no you know i
understand they have coverage issues uh
with the pittsburgh steelers but at the
same time their their their cover
corners are the big issues safety play
minka fitzpatrick's a free safety slash
nickelback right he's not a guy that you
want down in the box that's what he's
been complaining about as far as what
the dolphins have been asking him and
he's not a guy that you're gonna put
outside and go hey we want you on an
island and you just shut down the other
team's best receiver that's not what he
is and i just don't see how it fixes
their problems right now and yes for the
future mike you made the point i mean
this is a team that could very well be
on the verge of semi rebuilding here
starting a new era this next offseason
and you might have a top 15 pick and you
might have another desperate need
somewhere along uh your roster
especially at the quarterback position
or maybe somewhere else so to me it does
not make sense i was shocked to see it
go down
you know pittsburgh now is going to have
just i think like one pick
in the top 110 of this draft they don't
have their one they don't have their
three they use their three to move up on
draft night uh the first night of the
draft to get devin bush
and you know with denver and so now even
if there is a bumper crop of
quarterbacks in the draft next year the
steelers have priced themselves out of
the market by getting minka fitzpatrick
so
i believe that ben roethlisberger has
given them very strong indications that
he not only is going to play in 2020 but
he's going to play at least one year
beyond that now you heard out of the
steelers yesterday you heard out of
pittsburgh that roethlisberger intends
to fulfill his contract which
i mean if you're a pittsburgh fan and
you don't really know about mason
rudolph well you're happy about that
because you want to know that you have
the security blanket of roethlisberger
for a couple more years you know people
can say well he's really getting old ben
roethlisberger had the most passing
yards in football last year and he did
it navigating the mayhem that was
antonio brown
so i i still think that i i i chris i
agree with you mostly
but in my opinion yeah i want to know
what do the pittsburgh steelers see
right as the long-term future for minka
fitzpatrick what position is he going to
play will he play that nickel because
you're right they've got two good
safeties right now right if he can play
that nickel remember the nickel guy in
football right now last year played
about 72 percent of the snaps no doubt
so that's a guy who basically is your
12th starter yeah so now let's see
exactly what the steelers do with them
and remember he's only in his second
season they'll have that 50-year option
that they undoubtedly will exercise so
they have make a fitzpatrick for three
more years beyond the duration of this
one so they're getting him very very
early in his career and again there is
something in him that they must love
they must have coveted him secretly on
that first night of the draft in 2018
and now they have him but to get back to
the quarterback position peter i don't
know that i have the same faith that ben
rothersburg is going to hold together i
mean he had the entire offseason to get
himself ready and through all that
period of everybody's in the best shape
of their lives and everything's great
and there's no indication there's
anything wrong with him from a health
standpoint he comes out of the game week
one with an elbow problem by the end of
week two he's shut down for the season i
don't know that i have faith that the
guy's gonna hold together and you know i
made this point yesterday you look at
tom brady look at everything he's done
to commit himself to the lifestyle
necessary to play football as long as
possible and you look at ben
rothersberger and i don't see much that
suggests to me he's been doing
everything he possibly can to get the
most out of his body to play well into
his 40s and it could be his body is just
saying hey ben time's up
mike mike i think that's a really valid
point and you know that's something i
learned when i was there in pittsburgh
again with peter i don't mean to keep
bringing it up but you know you saw my
little interview i did with him about
what he does in the off season and
quarterback mechanics and things of that
he says he doesn't throw in the
off-season he doesn't do anything he
just comes to training camp now the day
we were there um i you know i had heard
there had been a little some tendonitis
issues and he we did an interview and he
had a huge thing of ice on his arm on a
day where peter will verify this he
didn't really partake in the team drills
of practice he did a little at the
beginning and some of the the one-on-one
position group type of drills and then
did nothing else so it is a little
concerning that way because you're right
big ben is not necessarily going to be
famous for his off-season regimen and
getting you know avocado ice cream and
doing every little thing in the world to
be ready to go it's just a different guy
he's different than tom brady that way
that's for sure
he's more of he's more of the
quarterback of even before your father
right and that is you know he's like a
he's like a sonny jurgensen or a billy
kilmer you know he's one of those guys
who you know is not really going to
spend the five months of the off season
or six months whatever it is he's not
going to spend that time you know
devoting himself to his body he just
never has been that guy now mike you
know you could be right you really could
be right uh in that you don't know what
the future holds for him physically and
i would agree with that but
i also think that you know there are so
many things that that teams and
physicians can do with players today
versus what they could do even 20 years
ago
and in my opinion
if there were a bunch of red flags up
right now about ben roethlisberger's
long-term future
i don't think they would have traded
that one for minka fitzpatrick i think
this trade was done in part yeah because
the steelers believe that ben
roethlisberger is going to be their
quarterback in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports